hello believe nation today we're going
to look at the seven things you should
do before quitting your job and as
always guys if you hear a point that
really resonates with you please leave
it down comments below for quote
surrender to other people can be
inspired as well and also writing it
down helps you lock it into yourself to
enjoy so I've always been an advocate of
you don't need to quit your job and go
into your business full-time I've always
been a fan of doing that on the side and
then eventually getting to the point
where you can quit your job and then go
full-time on your company and here are
my seven things that you should look at
before you take that leap full-time
[Music]
number one is think about taking another
job this might sound a little
counterintuitive because we're talking
about quitting our job and going
full-time the reason I have a job is to
learn the reason to have a job is to
make it income right you're paying off
your bills and you're learning and so be
looking at my current job right now if
you're not making enough from your own
business to quit and you need to have a
job then are you learning enough in the
business that you're in right now
are you learning the skills are going to
help you with your own company if not
then I'd be looking at how do I get
those skills somewhere else how do I
quit my job and before going all into my
business I have a bridge step at another
company where I'm going to learn when
you're growing up you pay to get a
university education here you are
getting paid to get educated you're
getting paid to make mistakes you're
getting paid to make contact in the
industry and so if you're looking at a
company that has 10 employees or less
that's in the industry that you want to
be in the company that you look up to
want to be like and aspire to learn from
and go work for them and get as close to
the co-founder as possible learn learn
learn or learn
take on as many projects as possible
even though they're outside what you
were specifically hired for so that when
you go off and start your own company or
when you try to build that thing up you
have all the tools all the experience
all the contacts necessary to do so and
so if you're not getting those tools
experienced in contracting the current
job I look for a different job first
[Music]
number two is figure out your business
idea so one of the great things about
being in an industry that you love is
you get to see how businesses work and
you get to see where the opportunities
are and so some of the great business
has been founded by people who are in an
industry they have a job they were
talking to customers and the customers
that you were talking to their needs
couldn't be solved by the current
company and whenever you hear
frustrations from your customer base and
the company you're working at can't
handle that situation that's an
opportunity you want to always take into
yourself it is something for me here can
I help this customer can I help them on
the side can I turn this into my own
business somehow when you're working in
the industry you want to pay attention
to where the holes are where the market
opportunities are where the pain points
are and figure out what your idea is
going to be for a unique offering to the
market the number three thing to do is
figure out a plan you need to have a
plan either think about once you have
your idea now how will you build a
business around it how are you going to
get new customers how are you going to
market yourself how are you going to
service the customers that you get in
how are you going to get word-of-mouth
marketing happening what's your social
media plan going to be you start to have
a plan now understand the thing about
planning the plan is never going to be
perfect a lot of times people spend too
much time on the plan they plan they
plan the plan they plan they never do
that's not the solution either but you
don't want to just jump all in and not
have a plan planning even though as soon
as you start actually being in business
your plan will change it doesn't mean
that the planning process is as valuable
so you want to have a plan you want to
do your research you want to get
everything together
and give yourself some confidence that
this thing is going to work before just
jumping all in on basically you want to
get to the point where if somebody
presented this thing to you you would
want to invest in so this looks like a
good plan this looks like a good idea
has that level of research and details
gone into your plan to help you get to
the point where you could comfortably
show it to somebody else oh say that's a
really good idea for the number four tip
I'm going to turn it over to my friend
Matthew from the YouTube channel Trident
lion
what's up believe nation Matthew aka
Trident lion from the Trident lion
channel and
number four is quit your job with low or
no-risk
not all entrepreneurs have the luxury
and capability to take and tolerate
massive risk many of us including myself
have children we need to provide for
hypothetically it's better to jump ship
by building a better ship while you're
on your current ship rather than jumping
ship and trying to build a ship while
you're swimming imagine being able to
leave your job quit with confidence and
certainty quit with your next source of
income being your entrepreneurial dream
the way to do this is to work if you
want it bad enough you have to put in
the work after hours I came across the
question a few years ago the question of
how do you build a personal brand and or
business while supporting a family and
working full-time and one of the best
answers I found is the advice of one of
my and Evans virtual mentors Gary
Vaynerchuk so for all of you
entrepreneurs out there that cannot
tolerate risk but still want to build
your entrepreneurial dream here is one
powerful and effective way how to do
exactly that
so if you have a feel if you want to do
it I don't want to hear about this
nine-to-five bull what's that
your questions I quit nice I don't want
to hear about this to drop job thing
right 9:00 to 5:00 I don't have time if
you want this if you're miserable or if
you don't like it or you want to do
something else and you have a passion
somewhere else work 9:00 to 5:00 spend a
couple hours of your family 7 to 2:00 in
the morning is plenty of time to do
damage but that's it it's not going to
happen any other way how do you get
money to do what you love you don't
write
I lost a shitload of money when I
started doing what I loved what you do
is you position yourself to succeed so
for example if you're doing something
else
and you and you want to do this thing
you love you do it after hours you work
9:00 to 6:00 you get home you kiss the
dog and you go to town right I mean you
start building your equity in your brand
and whatever you're trying to accomplish
after hours you everybody has time stop
watching lost
[Music]
by putting in the work and being patient
it is possible to turn your
entrepreneurial dream into your career
with practically no risk quitting your
job with certainty if you want to quit
your job without the risk putting in the
work towards your entrepreneurial dream
and being patient those are two
important things that you need to do
before you quit realize if you have a
busy schedule some of us like I said
have a full time job and children so
dedicating time for your entrepreneurial
dream can be limited time efficiency and
time effectiveness should be taken
serious you don't want to waste your
limited time building entrepreneurial
dream on unimportant tasks one great
solution to this is to utilize Pareto's
law consider and ask yourself what is
the most important 20% of the work that
goes into building my entrepreneurial
dream for 80% of the outcome if you want
to quit your job to have a career doing
your entrepreneurial dream with little
to no risk like Gary Vee has said do it
after hours put in the work be patient
be persistent learn as you go grow as
you learn and be sure to never quit on
creating a life doing your personal
entrepreneurial dream so there you have
the number 4 thing to do before quitting
your job my number 5 tip is run the
numbers so I think you should start at a
company and then do your business on the
side and the point where you leave your
job to go into your business full-time
is when you can make enough from your
business to pay off all your bills so
you can know how much it costs you to
live your life every month and it
doesn't have to be a life of luxury
we're not talking about going out and
buy an expensive car and we're going off
on expensive trips just the basics food
internet mortgage or rent what does that
equal every month you know here's what I
have to make
from my business to survive and if you
can get to that point as part-time
entrepreneur then you know listen I
could quit my job I could spend full
time now working on my business and I
have enough to cover my basics now that
I'm spending more time on my business I
can rapidly grow it up and earn more as
well but you can't do that if you know
the numbers the run the number to know
how much you need to survive and how
much you're making them your business so
number six is then start on the side we
want to get started don't just have this
idea and do nothing about it it's not
just have a job or learn about the
industry and then wait for some magical
moment to start no like start now start
on this side start immediately weekends
even we're going right away to try to
build our business up even if it's free
work at the start even if it's spec work
just to build up your portfolio just to
build up your experience just to build
up the the connections and understanding
how the industry works it's worth it on
the side to start building some momentum
because it's going to take a while to
get your company off the ground it's not
just going to happen for you and so
starting now starting and sucking right
starting and improving slowly slowly
slowly slowly take everything that you
learn from your company that you have
your job at and you put it into your own
business building that up and not
waiting because too many people have
these great ideas while they're at a job
and maybe the job sucks or maybe the job
is great but you still just sit on the
idea you don't do anything with it with
the key is to do something with it and
the hardest part is you have this big
vision for where you want to go and you
know you can't do it right now and a lot
of people just sit on the vision they
just sit on the idea well you stick to
the big vision this is the big thing
that we want to do that I want to build
but I'm starting here and I'm going to
take a step and another step and another
step in another step it's thinking big
and acting small most people think big
and act zero do nothing so find a way to
start today immediately every single day
you're spending time on your business to
move your idea forward
[Music]
and then number seven is hit your
survival number this is the last step
once you hit that survival number and
you know here's what I need to live and
I've hit it it's having a courage to
save I'm ready to go you know I may be
taking a pay cut I'm not making as much
as I am now with my combined salaries
from my business and the job I have but
this business is the thing that you
wanted to build you put your survival
number it's having the courage to leave
that job take all the time you spent
there and pour it into your company and
really build something you can be proud
of
so once you've hit that to the viable
number you got to have the courage to
act to do it to take the leap to jump
and to have the confidence that you're
saying is going to work out so that's my
take on the seven things that you need
to do before quitting your job I love to
know what did you guys think which rule
is your favorite if you have an 8 9 10
that you'd like to add to the list leave
it down in the comments below and I'm
going to join in the discussion I also
want to thank Matthew from Trident line
for his point number four as well
Matthew picked up a copy of my book gear
one word and made an awesome book review
on his channel as well so thank you
Matthew for the love I really really
appreciate it and I'm glad that you
enjoyed the book as well now I would
like to express some gratitude Evan
Carmichael thank you for having me on
this video and being featured on your
channel also thank you for your book
your one word creating the summary and
review on it was so fun to do and it
certainly has helped my self and my
brand level up so thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love how
theses
you